سيد الولاء بدون منازع على موائد الاردنيه
المنسف الاكله الشعبيه ذائعه الصيت
الحاضره في الافراح والاطراح والمناسبات
وليمه اجتماعيه توجت من قبل منظمه
اليونسكو ضمن التراث العالمي الثقافي غير
المادي للانسانيه
كثيرا ما تقوم على وليمه المنسف اقتصادات
منزليه للسيدات تهنفن تطويع الحليب واللبن
لانتاج الجميل المكون الرئيسي للمنسف
تبرع منال الصعود في انتاج الجليد من حليب
الضان والماعز دون اضافات صناعيه وسرعان
ما تقوم هنا بفصل الزبده عن الحليب كي
يتخثر ويتماسك
لتبدا بعدها بانتاج اللبن الرائب والسمنه
الطبيعيه قبل اعداد الجميل باشكال متنوعه
كثير وصار عند التسويق لخارج محافظه الكرك
لاغلب محافظات الاردن
وفي ادراج المنسف على القائمه العالميه
وكان نجح قبلها في ادراج غناء السامر
البدوي منفردا وبجهد مشترك مع الدول
العربيه في تسجيل النخله والخط العربيين
ضمن القائمه نفسها
بالمعنى
الطعام اهميه الطعام والشراب لاي ثقافه
ثقافتنا الاردنيه ولكن الاهم من ذلك هو
القيم المرتبطه بالمنسف في الاردن
الضيافه العربيه لاكرام الضيف والمسافر
وكثيرا ما قالوا انه اجمل الهدايا واكثرها
قيمه حسب باحثين في التراث وجبه يعود
تاريخها وفق بعض الروايات الى عهد الملك
ميشع ملك دوله مهاب ومؤسس مدينه الكرك قبل
نحو ثلاثه الاف عام
رائد عواد الجزيره الكرك جنوبي الاردن